I'm a lawyer based in Chicago,
and two months ago I represented
a Vietnamese immigrant woman
in her divorce.
As she was testifying
about how her husband brutally raped her,
the judge repeatedly told her
to stop speaking.
She should only speak
when I asked her a question.
Can you imagine having to publicly
share one of the most painful,
traumatic moments in your life
and being told over and over again
to basically shut up?
It felt so wrong,
but also so familiar for me.
My mother,
she had no say in her divorce.
She didn't have a lawyer,
so she signed papers
giving away everything
because she thought she would otherwise
be deported back to Vietnam.
I thought by becoming a lawyer,
I could help people like my mother.
But then I realized I was actually
part of the problem.
As lawyers, we take over
speaking for our clients.
And courtroom procedures,
rules of evidence means
that we have all the power
in what happens in their cases.
We take terrible situations
from people's lives
and we translate it into legal language.
But, in doing so,
we rewrite our clients as caricatures.
The most helpless, most victimized
versions of themselves.
This is the American legal system.
And that's why, eight years ago,
I founded Beyond Legal Aid
in the belief that it doesn't
have to be this way,
and lawyers can actually
change it, working within,
making it so that clients
can speak for themselves.
How does this work?
First, instead of working nine to five
in offices downtown,
we travel, go to our clients
where they live.
And during evenings,
nights and weekends
when they are available.
And they can be active participants
in the legal process.
Next, let me share a little secret.
Well, at least for the non-lawyers.
Attorneys like to be in charge.
We go to law school,
we hang up fancy law degrees,
and we wear fancy suits --
obviously much fancier
than what I’m wearing --
because we want to be in control.
But it’s our clients
whose lives are being judged
and impacted by what I do.
They need to be full partners
in charge of their own cases.
We can give advice,
empower them to navigate the legal system.
But ultimately,
we need to follow their lead
and defer to their decisions.
Let me give you an example.
One of our clients,
let's call him Atticus,
he was facing deportation in a case
where the law was completely against us.
Atticus had been in ICE detention
for several months
because the immigration judge
denied him bond.
So he and OCAD, the Organized
Communities Against Deportation,
the community group
we were working with on his case,
wanted to try for bond a second time.
I and the other lawyers were like,
"No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You can't do that.
The law is bad,
the judge has already said no once,
and we don't want to piss him off
by questioning his decision."
But they wanted to proceed,
so we deferred to their decision.
However, instead of my sharing
his situation on his behalf,
we convinced the judge
to hear a live conversation
between Atticus and his US citizen son,
let's call him Jem.
Jem spoke about how he wanted
to commit suicide
because he couldn't live
without his father anymore.
Atticus broke down,
sobbing in despair
because he felt responsible
for what was happening with his son
and yet couldn't be there for him.
The judge was forced to hear directly
how Atticus and Jem loved each other
and how much they needed each other.
He heard it unadulterated, in full,
without any questions,
without any interruptions by any lawyers.
Unfortunately, he denied
bond a second time.
But --
and of course there’s a “but,” right,
otherwise, I wouldn't
be telling you this story.
(Laughter)
The judge then cancelled
Atticus’s deportation.
I cannot tell you how utterly,
absolutely shocking
that legal victory was.
(Applause)
I was like, "Oh my God,
I can't believe this happened."
And ...
I’m going to say something now,
which lawyers don’t say very often
but probably should say a lot more often.
I was wrong.
My client and his community,
they knew better.
If we had not followed their lead
and tried for bond a second time,
the judge would have never heard
Atticus tell his own story
and be so moved by what was going on
that he defied the law
to allow Atticus to stay
in the country with his son.
Atticus being able to tell his own story,
created a decision that was impossible,
at least what we thought as attorneys.
Atticus sharing and talking his own case
created justice where the law was wrong.
And that's why the legal
system has to change,
so that people like Atticus
can share their own stories,
have agency over their own cases.
In the meantime, we as lawyers need
to make it happen in our work,
in our cases right now.
Thank you.
(Applause)